I know you dance you're very good dancer
you started dancing when you were like
in the womb right how you were I mean
you were how old when you started
dancing um I pretty much you know
started dancing ever since I was born
but I've started you know taking dance
and you know I've always wanted to do
something with dance ever since I'd like
been four or five I'd say and like a lot
of where I've came from now is is from
the dance community so like everything
I've learned how to not be you know
always be confident you know not be shy
they've they've always taught me that so
you know they're just really great and I
pretty much you know learn all my dance
moves you you should when you start as a
gesture your name was baby Boogaloo yeah
I wanted that name but they said it was
taken I hope you also you rap as well is
that true yeah I do am i dad you write
your own stuff yeah I'm I I do and my
dad also helps me come up with certain
things as well my dad's a rapper I shout
out to my dad who's backstage but um
yeah I want to shout out to my dad he's
a microbiologist
yeah we tell him he is so what can you
give us an example I'd love to hear you
rap yeah sure you know if you if you
feel like it
all right cool all right dream big you
could do anything it doesn't have to
revolve around fame I'm not done I
desire plenty that's why I dream big to
inspire many yeah we young see but we
hungry might be the next to control this
whole country trying to reach higher
then I can stand to keep touching this
inspiration all around me and if my
reach is too far like whoever said the
journey wouldn't be hard right you might
even get knocked down before you find
yourself stepping into the limelight
with great power comes great
responsibility you need unlimited
positive energy and the love must be
surrounded like an electric current
keeping you grounded like the best
friend who has your back me and Conan we
go way back
you
you